Всім привіт Мене звати Марія мадзігон і
зараз ми знаходимось на Майдані
Незалежності в місті Київ Тому що
сьогодні зібрались люди щоб
відсвяткувати день нашого українського
прапора він у нас
синьо-жовтий за конституцією можете
відкрити
почитати забула номер статті по-моєму
20-та можу помилитись саме з номером там
написано що кольори прапора
синьо-жовтий вони один над іншим тому
сьогодні люди реально взяли багато
прапорів і зараз ми зобов'язані вам все
це показати оператор Андрій Луганський
теж передає вам
привіт і Ходімо поспілкуємось запитаємо
у людей навіщо вони взагалі вихідний
день оце нічого вам робити скажете ви
ходити по майданах з прапорами але це
наше свято це наша Символіка це те
що ми брали з собою на майдан в
13-му-14му році коли ось тут відбувались
ті події Революція Гідності це наша
Гідність це частина нашої гідності наша
ідентичність в тому плані що це наша
символіка і одразу ж можна зрозуміти до
речі по різних акціях наші люди завжди
приходять із прапором це якби такий
своєрідний маркер проукраїнськості це
своєрідний маркер патріотів тому що от я
знаю що Точно Андрій Луганський з собою
носить прапор завжди він щойно його
діставав і казав що він його носить
завжди не хочеш розповісти у тебе такий
цікавий він дуже незвич я тебе
зніму Вітаю всіх прапор завжди зі мною в
мене на наплічнику на тому на рюкзакі
бачите отака стрічка Вона завжди Вона
завжди є це вона так постійно тут є
це наш український символ
і прапор завжди зі мною такий прапор
подарували мені наші глядачі він такий
бачите його не
потрібно зав'язувати якось там
обмоталась в нього є бачите рукавитак от
я раз вдягаю дуже зручно Дуже дякую
глядачам за це що хотів би розказати
якщо мене чути і взагалі будь ласка
напишіть від Ну до
чи видно мене звук від Ну до 10 відео і
напишіть Звідки ви нас
дивитесь бо якщо там якісь проблеми зі
звуком бо там гучна музика грає ми
трошки Так відійнемо я вам розкажу про
прапор особисто свої враження бо це для
мене дуже
важливо сила іздвоє грає клас В 14му
році
коли починаючи десь з весни і вже влітку
в Луганську Майже неможливо було
зустріти українські прапори вони геть
зникли і там де зникає український
прапор там де зникає українська влада і
взагалі
Україна становиться десь там вже подалі
а луганць перетворюється на щось
незрозуміле разом з прапором разом з
українським прапором разом з нашою
українськістю там зникає
правокакає н зникає
справедливість і в Луганську не це
відчувалось не було прапорів і прапори
малювали вночі
хлопці у виді графіті знаєте просто от
фарбами фарбами замальовували так дерева
замальовували якісь будівлі Це було дуже
важливо потім оці ватноголої вони
перехрещували там красним да а видно
було що прапор великий такий намалювали
фарбою а вони писали тамрос я
знаєте така фарба така масляна навіть не
та не для графіті і вони перемогли свій
час ті хлопці які за допомогою графіті
Показували що Луганськ - це Україна на
жаль це не допомогло але інформаційно це
було важливо і вже коли в кінці літа
14го року ми перетинали лінію зіткнення
там були дуже були таке дуже запеклі бої
і ми
перейшли переїхали вже на сторону за Ниц
Луганську Там же в де же де були Наші
хлопці і я побачив перший прапор перший
за декілька місяців перший прапор
України який був на бтрі такий був
солдат він на лице був чорний від копоті
від сажі від війни в нього такі глаза
були очі були такі білі а е обличчя таке
було чорне і прапор був такий на бтрі
він такий був подряпаний знаєте який ну
прапори я ви вже бачили 100 000 разів
коли хлопці привозять їх з фронту вони
дуже важливі для них такі знаєте
подряпані від бою від пожарів там я знаю
від пожеж і ну на очах з'являлися сльози
не тільки в мене а багатьох хто був от
поруч там в нас їхало десь людей 15 може
там 17 Це було дуже важливо бо відчуваєш
що прапор є дуже
важлива дуже важливий такий аспект дуже
важлива
навіть тому що коли ти
його втрачаєш і потім його знов бачиш що
ти на Україні Що ти от на тій Землі де є
закон порядок де є право де є свобода І
ти відчуваю що прапор - це дуже важливо
і У кожного з вас не я Я впевнений у
кожного з вас по всій території України
хто був на війні і хто переселенець або
хто просто В кого болить за Україну у
вас є особлива історія про ваш прапор
напишіть цю історію це дуже важливо коли
читаєш такі історії вони надихають на те
щоб спротив цієї російської навалі
продовжувався бо Ну вже багато років ми
це робимо з вами а український прапор
він крутіший і він бачите люди хто же
хто може заплатити людям цим щоб вони
прийшли посвяткувати свято прапора ніхто
А у кожного з них бачите або стрічка або
прапор як символ якогось захисту бо
прапор захищає там де є прапор там де є
Україна там є закон порядок і Свобода
Слава Україні Вітаю вас всіх зі святом
продумжуєго стрім
щойна бачила жінку Я зараз її пошукаю У
неї є особливий прапор За який от у мене
зачепилась увага дуже сильно спробую її
знайти пропоную вам піти прогулятися
показати якби що
Дивіться Я вас прошу коли раптом можливо
перерветься зв'язок або ще щось буде ви
одразу ж напишіть в чат щоб ми знали що
потрібно наприклад повернутись назад і
там шукати інший зв'язок я не знаю
хороший щоб ми орієнтувались тому будемо
з вами тримати такий зворотній зв'язок
постійно і
Ходімо тут є Хто не був на
Майдані
Вітаю е Хто не був на Майдані тут є такі
такий своєрідний це напевно музеєм
експозицією можна назвати і тут стенди
де описуються революції в Україні
взагалі і окремо Революція Гідності
двома мовами українською та англійською
тому ось ці такі штуки якщо ви їх не
бачили то це якби частина на експозиції
просто щоб Можливо хтось не
[музика]
знає Зараз я
стріміі зараз напрямий чи куди у нас
ефір ефір ефір
хочу показати цієї жінки футболку покажи
така класна вишиванка у вас
взагалі що для вас означає
прапор прапор для мене
означає не тільки державний символ але
це для мене напевно ще символ нашої
незалежності нашої незлавності я навіть
сьогодні допис писала в Фейсбуці що коли
розумієш ее як наші хлопці Захисники
бійці наші
ее ціною власного ну навіть життя можна
так сказати загроза для них є така йго
їх власному життю встановлюють прапори
по всій лінії фронту то для мене це вже
напевно святе
це вже більше ніж просто державний
символ Дякую вам це відчуття дому Це
відчуття нашої єдності це гордість ну
Для мене це дуже
багато згодна абсолютно з
вами А де інші партії Я не розумію що ти
кажеш А де інші партії бачу європейська
Солідарність бачу справа громади А де
той ну наші українські
партії Що там Що там інше є ще які там
проукраїнські партії ще є десь вони за
Україну де українсь треба запитати в
людей треба
запитиркова
бачимо палатка намету європейська
Солідарність бачимо справа громад інші
партії українські чого нема Я
европейская солідарность и справа громад
А где остальные Я не знаю ніхто не знає
ніхто не знає цікаве спостереження
Напишіть що ви думаєте про це це цікаво
а дивіться тут зробили таку по-перше цей
намет тут стоїть бо тут є аптечка і
перша допомога Раптом що потрібно
по-друге тут є анкети волонтерів і ось
тут справа громад вони зробили свої такі
магніти
і з різних різних місць ось наприклад є
справа громад
Київ справа громад
Тернопіль це люди які завжди приїжджають
з інших міст вони активісти у нас в
різних містах проводять рейд різні
проводять свої акції і от вони скрізь
скрізь скрізь
єсь справа громан така
от об'єднує
людей тому кому цікаво долучайтесь до
європейської солідарності кому цікаво
долучайтесь до справи громад Скрізь у
нас є
активісти просто об'єднуємо активних
людей щоб так було легше
комунікувати от Юрій каракайм відповість
до інші партії
100% Привіт Ми шукаємо де інші партії от
бачимо тут є європейська Солідарність і
ще є справа громад і все А де інші це
мене тішить я інших партій взагалі не
бачу на небослі української політики
тільки є
ЗМІ немає немає просто от де де
проукраїнські ті що найбільше вирещать
потім де вони всі хто їх знає Ну а хто
хто хто Ну я на назви я просто можу
навіть пригадати Які в нас ще є
проукраїнські партії ареба щоб глядачі
Пригадали які ще є проукраїнські партії
глядачі
напишуть Кіра Рудик де Кіра Рудик де
Кіра не цілинь
гелікоптернає
накрасві і бійці
спеціальногозначеня вирушають усі
по
повертаться ось Т краще як долучитись до
справи громад як долучитися до справи
громад все дуже просто ви Заходите на
сайт
spgr.org.ua і реєструєтесь коли ви
зареєструвалися ви становитеся нашим
прихильником все ви ви уже вже з нами
але якщо ви хочете щось більше ви хочете
стати нашим учасником ви можете
заповнити там у вас в особистому
кабінеті є заява на вступ та декалог
документ який підтверджує що ми з вами
одної крові як то кажуть да у нас з вами
одна мета і одна ідеологія ви заповните
загружаєте документи обратно ми це
бачимо і приймаємо вже в нас вас в
учасники справи громад з особистими
відповідальностями вжеж Я думаю що на
сайті ви все зрозумієте це
антонана як ти думає всі інші політичні
партії ми бачимо лише європейську
Солідарність і справу громад А де всі
інші проукраїнські партії мабуть
готуєтьсяк завтрашні події а День
Прапора якби це теж важливе
свято Я на жаль не знаю
більш патріотичної партії ніж
європейська Солідарність міськузі це моє
особисте але мабуть вони що Зробили десь
так що ми не бачимо не знаю але для нас
цей день дуже важливий прапор України у
мене сьогодні в Фейсбуці вся лента в
прапорах це дуже файно дуже круто і то
що буде відбуватися зараз тут у нас це
для мене Ну я так розумію що найбільша
подія в Україні Окрім цього що бу було
вчора
Дякую це була Антоніна гозіло голова
правління справи
громад ми таємно нем за країну життя
невагаючи іння і заіли значить
затіла доми
за
[музика]
тихо йшов тихо
пішов знище я
нака сідає ніч наступає доні
спец я знаю точно що в наступному році
на День Прапора рі буде тут разом з нами
він зараз перебуває в заручниках
нинішньої влади і ми його обов'язково
звільнимо це наш разом з вами обов'язок
ми запитуємо на твою думку от
дно прапори європейської солідарності
справи громад А де інші патріотичні сили
знаю запрошували аблютноі
Я не знаю чому не прийшли але ще день не
завершився в них є дуже великий шанс
разом з усіма об'єднано відсвяткувати це
дуже чудове і важливе свято для всієї
країни Слава Україні Слава Нації і ми
обов'язково переможеу обов'язково це був
Олександр
погрибиський
друзі обов'язково підписуйтесь на цей
канал і ставте вподобайки щоб не
пропускати такі прямі ефіри Поки ви
зараз всі тут і всі зараз
дивитесь
доб вечо шановне
панство давайте потрох готуватися до
нашої сьогоднішньої події перш за все
сильно сильно дякую тим хто прийшли
сьогодні Мене звати Віталій гайдукевич Я
один з координаторів справи громад перш
за все всі ті хто прийшли заради нашої
події розгортання одного з найдовших
порів наших будь ласка збираємося трохи
нижче на кілька на кілька сходинок
спускаємося Я зараз поясню чому чисто
технологічний момент прапор наш має 33 м
будь ласка мене слухайте і будь ласка
проходьте ось сюди трохи нижче просто по
центру сходинок Ми почнемо його
розгортати між двома стендами інституту
національної пам'яті в бік Хрещатику
тому ви всі наші помічники які
допоможуть це
зробити нам допомагати чекай Ніні Ні
зараз ми все поволі Ось все правильно
буквально на один Ярос вниз отак от
спускаємося Ну А
далі спритність
рук
так поки о Спасибі майже всі
передислухувалися в такому разі я
буквально кілька слів зауважу що кожного
року на день нашого прапора Ми
намагаємося так чи інакше вшанувати наші
Два кольори які стали символом
державності і х поколінь за те щоб ця
державність була для нас і наших дітей
цього року завдяки нашим активістам з
Полтавщини Вікторія Так зараз зараз вони
скажуть навіщо вони це придумали завдяки
нашим активістам з Полтавщини прапор
який народився завдовжки в 20 м в
процесі своїх мандрів Україною доріз до
33 це майже як лист дяді фдора батькам
коли всі потроху дописували на ньому
своє зокрема і побажання зокрема і
бажання і доточували цей прапор в
кожному місті і от власне зараз
33 33 м чому Так навіщо відправили
мандрувати прапор по містах скільки міст
він об'їхав
Вікторія Слава Україні
громада слава Слава нації срес ворога
Україна понад усе звикли ми так
представлятися а я по-перше хочу
представити вам координатора нашого
осередку солідарна Полтава справи громад
Марія горбитенко на щастя Це моя дитина
якою я капец як пишаюся і саме завдяки
її роботі її вмінню об'єднувати навколо
себе людей у нас дійсно в Полтаві дуже
потужний оередок який складається саме з
однодумців з людей які працюють які
створюють все на навколо себе в такому
ракурсі що єдина Україна єдина Полтава
єдина держава це все єдине
І зараз я передам їй слово спочатку хай
вона розповість як була створена ця ідея
стосовно прапора а потім ще може щось
додам Слава Україні Слава десь близько
два місяці тому ми вирішили зробити
прапор єдності прапор єдності справи
громад Ми почали спілкуватися з
координаторами вирішили які будуть міста
Приймати участь і розпочали шити прапор
готуватися збирати мапу збиратися по
Україні тож прапо вирушив з Полтави він
почав мандрувати по всій Україні і для
нашого здивування було те що це вже було
не прапор єдності справи громад Це був
прапор єдності всієї України приходили
патріоти партійці люди яким не байдуже
Україна приходили і підписували прапор
писали
побажання побажання щоб країна була наша
квітуча єдина і вільна і нам дуже
приємно що саме наш прапор прапор
єдності наших наших українців набув
масштабу такого Великого що він виріс що
він став набагато більше ніж виходив з
Полтави я дякую моїй команді Яка зараз в
Полтаві яка
зараз
робить неймовірні речі ми то зараз тут а
вони в Полтаві працюють і так Зараз усіх
по всій Україні є велика команда
величезна яка є єдина І саме прапор
єдності об'єднав всю Україну навколо і
для мене це дужедуже
великий для мене це велика подяка для
всіх
українців
Спасибі Спасибі за те що підкинули тепер
всім клопіт тому що тепер вся команда
справи громад і Київська і по містах
думає
власне як далі Житиме цей 30тиметровий
прапор Який Ось зараз колеги вже
практично готові розгортати Єві версії в
принципі я думаю ми можемо навіть на
обговорення запустити наших прибічників
або наступного року він знову затри
місяці до дня незалежності почне
подорожувати знову по містах там де він
ще не був і 33 м доштикуються ще 33
метрами або ми маємо знайти місце де ці
33 м щирості і патріотизму українців
можна буде побачити Ну у нас є
трох додам Так давай Напевно що стаємо
тут щоб ми щоб просто ми розуміли Де він
є і могли оперативно це Ні Ні поки не
розгортаємо щоб просто він у нас був в
центрі в центрі
подій І власне який вибір зробити
стосовно подальшої долі прапора це я
думаю ми всією громадою ж справа громад
і будемо
вирішувати Я хочу ще додати те що наш
самоосередок солідарно Полтава він один
з наймолодших осередків по всій Україні
ми
стартанули в березні цього року але ми
дуже намагалися бути Ну достойними цієї
команди ми трудилися ми працювали ми
підтримували і дуже дякуємо всім всім
осередкам країни які допомагали нам і
підтримували нас тому я просто впевнена
що крок за кроком місяць за місяцем у
нас будуть єднуватися осередки по всій
країні Я дуже вірю що якщо дійсно ми
будемо ще дошивати дошивати і дошивати і
цей прапор набуде дуже величезних
розмірів доєднуйтесь до справою громад
там реально круті люди які мотивують які
Ну дійсно це один єдиний пулак в якому
тримається Довіра в якому тримається
робота в якому тримається патріотизм і
якщо це випускається то створюються такі
осередки ну от як наш підтримуйте нас
будь ласка це важливо
Спасибі Ну і напевно щоб ми вже були
абсолютно щирі в нашому таймінгу щоб
близько 7мої ми змогли починати
розгортати прапор Я ще раз нагадаю що ми
почнемо звідси і нам Тут будуть потрібні
ваші руки поза як прапор довгенький і
треба його тримати з усіх боків це буде
першим кроком і другим кроком та людина
яка запросить нас всіх зробити
розвертання прапора власне і підпише цей
прапор і ми всі хто бажає якщо є така
можливість зможемо залишити на тому
прапорі побажань тому одразу Зрозумійте
яким чином ми розтягнемося
через через Майдан в бік хрищатика щоб
всі змогли тримати цей прапор давай тоді
одразу якщо можна нам в принципі є час
на одну-дві
пісні Владика звуку одна дві пісні поки
а і можна мікрофон не вимикати А ми
почнемо трохи готувати до
розгортання
мотор дайте весю
[музика]
песй
тільки не заважайте тому що ми маємо не
підходьте ті хто не буде тримати в
перших двох метрах щоб ми змогли
відмотати 1-2 Мери вбік Хрещатику і
потім сходами будемо спускати далі І
кожен зможе взяти на себе цю шляхетну
[музика]
ношу з
тобою знов засвітий сонце ранньою
весноюю
мійі кажу
шлях у з
моря це
цевою
[музика]
смітами чисди непаусу
до мами Мій друг нам з
тобою
збирайю нам з тобою
мікустою кажу
шлях на змих морях
поки що не розгортайте з повна не
розгортайте з повна ми маємо розрахувати
довжину тому готуємося до цієї миті
але
роздіти наші жадібні потреби за той там
Що до кінця буде тримати небо Мій друг
нам з тобою нам з тобою
Сора нам з тобою
мі добра тобі Дай
бо
нам з тобою нам з тобою бтя засвіти
сонце
[музика]
ююбоюмі шлях Уми
моря сзаб народ спускался вниз это
шановне панство тепер Всі хто тримають
прапор можна зробити хто ліворуч хто
праворуч але кілька кроків в бік
хрищатика не розгортаючи прапор просто
складеному вигляді кілька кроків в бік
Хрещатика Саме
так Саме
так
все все зупинилися і тепер треба просто
Подивіться щоб знамено це не має лежати
на підлозі коли ми його розгорнімо не
розгортаємо поки що дистанцію між собою
Зрозумійте хто саме буде тримаю щоб коли
розійшлися ліворуч праворуч можна було
знамено
натягнути
я йду від тебе і до
тебе у золотих твоїх стежках
Ні не можна не любити
і не можна не
свісти ощо ти варто в світі
жити
покружує ший
нети
Україна Україно
Після
далекі
морі Вірне
серце твого
сина як ду та
обідані
кохаєм
долестями і ще не скоро лиш кінець
лиш може своїми
серцямисяі
сер друзі ще одне велике прохання ви
будете роходитися бо серед нас є діти
просто обережно відступаються назад
друзі Зараз
чекаємо ще раз хто не дуже може там
зрозумів цей прапор
він їздив по всіх містах України і його
розгортали в усіх містах України куди
змогли його там Ну Знайти активістів
куди Він приїжджав і про нього знімали і
сюжети на телебаченні я бачила І взагалі
це відомо така штука І звісно Логічно що
фінальне місце - це серце столиці це
серце України це Київ Майдан
Незалежності ось тела незалежності Там
Майдан і зараз його там розгорнуть і ми
чекаємо коли це трапиться А ще я змогла
взяти собі маркер щоб теж на ньому
розписатись тому чекаємо
коли так давайте нам ідеї Андрій Я думаю
теж долучиться підпише що нам написати
на прапорі напишіть Просто щоби ви
написали А ми візьмемо одну із ваших
ідей і напишемо це хороша ідея Я думаю
пишіть в коментарях дав година і жви
слава слава України
Україно
с серце
го
[музика]
синаіі
Укра дуже довгий він Я так зрозуміла що
[музика]
широкий
друзі я акці в будь-якому Великому
проекті має бути та людина яка власне і
дасть старт справа громад Херсон чи був
у вашому місті цей прапор був розгортали
так розгортали а в скількох містах
розгортали ви не знаєте по-моєму 24 Якщо
я не помиляюся от Ми якраз стоїмо
напроти наших написів Ми навіть
наліпочки наліпили щоб потім не спутати
ми знали що ми знали що ми сьогодні Да
да да да да у нас Одеса неподалік мини
вчимося
тому Да у нас це була дуже крута акція І
після того як побачили нас нашим
прапором на Набережній в Херсоні нам
подарували не такий великий але 3 на 7 м
і ми тепер коли плетемо сітки для
хлопців ми вивішуємо цей великий прапір
розтягуємо до нас приєднуються Люди отак
наша справа громати поповнюється як до
вас долучитись в Херсоні в Херсоні
Оксана пагамій в Херсоні сторінка в
Херсоні сторінка солідарна справа громад
і справа громад Херсон група
Приєднуйтесь це буде щастя Дякую а я
питаю всіх де інші партії сьогодні що я
не бачу жодних представників партії
прапора жодної партії де вони всі
поділися вони мабуть завтра готуються
сидять телевізори так витирають тряпочка
щоби дивитися на наш марш незалежних
гідних справжніх і
нескорених па для того щоб зробити
правильні реі нашому житті і те що ми
робимо зараз є надзвичайно правильно як
прапор це не просто Два кольори це
символ
радий вітати тут п'ятий президент
України Петро Порошенко та перша леді
Марина горошенко саме їм випадає честь
дати початок розгортання прапору тільки
будь ласка друзі а не затовчіть
президента а б Дайте мені прийти до
президента щоби він сказав що прапор
можна розгортати майбутнь пане
президенте Слава Україні героя
Слава слухайте які ви всі
класні Подивіться скільки в нас які
зібралися тут на цьому Святому
місці
оптимізм бо свято державного прапора -
це одне зз найважливіших свят яке
святкує
Україна в цей день Ми піднімаємо
державний прапор і схиляємо
голову в
пам'ять про тих хто віддав своє життя
для того щоб існувала
Україну бо державний прапор державний
герб Державний Гімн це є той фундамент
побудови нашої
держави Я Хочу наголосити на то
що за те щоб цей прапор існував для того
щоби держава
існувала сотнями років українці
віддавали своє
життя наче священний
вогонь вони з цим трапором їхали в
табори
гулагу тримали його в криївках
УПА
зберігали в ститих
самвидаві
для того щоб
80ти мільйонів українців під цим
прапором і Під звуки ще не вмерла
Україна поховали
імперію нам це
вдалося але особливо
озвучення наш гімн і важливості наш
прапор
отримав під час Революції
гідності під час Революції
гідності
20 2
січня День
соборності вчитель з
Донецька Анатолій Чайка Тут поруч на
Грушевського відмовився віддавати
беіркутам наш прапор йому зламали обидві
кістки але він прапор не від
бо це був символ нашої Перемоги
майбутньої
Перемоги зараз також тут
недалеко музей історії України в другій
світовій війні
розгорнуто експозиція про порівне якій
представлені 43
прапори обов'язково ті хто нас зараз
дивиться по телебаченню і ті хто тут на
Майдані Незалежності найдть можливісті
дивитися цю експозицію там є прапор який
був піднятий над старим терміналом
Донецького
аеропорту там
є
прапор який був
піднятий двома фантастичними
людьми мирославом
гаєм Я десь його тут бачив бійцем
Національної гвардії
і Сергієм
шевчуком воїном славетної 95ї
аеромобільно-десантної бригади був
піднятий
на 120метрову телевежу на горі карачин
перед звільненням
слов'янську там
були
прапори шахти яку підняла 93 бригада
шахти бутівка Донецька
є ще
приклади величезного героїзму бо за цей
прапор українці демонстрували що вони не
бояться
загарбників Володимир Балух
героїчний
політв'язень підняв український
синьо-жовтий прапор над своєю будівлею в
окупованому Криму і потрапив заграти він
знав що його це чекає
але він демонстрував що українців не
залякати Володимира
Ми витягнули з
в'язниці звільнено Володимира
балуха справжнього героя і так як
Володимира балуха буде звільнений
український Крим і український
Донбас ми ще маємо згадати
героїчно Володимира Володимира
рибака який в
14-му зупинив
стягнення українського прапору з
захопленої російськими терористами
Горловки його
схопили багато годин котували і
вбили але він знав що він бореться за
Українську Державу і український прапор
я твердо
переконаний що саме український
прапор об'єднує всю Україну і всіх
українців нашої держави і всього
світу незалежно від мови незалежно від
національності незалежно від релігії це
як ідентифікатор свій
Чужий І недарма синьо-жовтими стрічками
наші воїни йшли боронити нашу державу
від російських окупантів і в них на
шевронах був синьо-жовтий
прапор дорогі
друзі
Я радий тому що на Майдані Я бачу
патріотів небайдужих людей твердо
впевнених в нашій перемозі і гаряче
любячих
Україну ті хто не знає
цього флешмобу він є неймовірний чи
Віталій Ти вже
розповів
але мені дуже подобається ця ініціатива
і сьогодні незважаючи на ті Випробування
які Господь посилає Україні на ті
Випробування які Господь посилає нашій
родині Марина прийми співчуття
бо вчора
ми поховали марининого батька але ми
точно
знаємо ми точно знаємо що Україна для
нас понад усе українська єдність понад
усе українська держава понад усе
український народ понад усе і наш рух до
Європейського Союзу і до НАТО збереже
Україну збереже український народ
збереже українську націю Слава Україні
Героям слава і слава тому державному
прапору України слава слава
слава а пер шановне панство трохи музики
яка відповідає цьому урочистому моменту
будьте обережні поруч вас можеть бути
діти і робимо
ліворучправоруч розходимося і розтягуємо
наш прапор кожен собі
потроху а
шаіле
трева
є я лише нагадаю це 23 міста це 33 м і
скоріш за все наступного року до х
метрів буде Додано ще і зараз всті хто
матимуть можливість якщоєтико на ручках
ми зможемо отримати можливість підписати
цей прапор Але перед тим кілька слів
скаже Марина
[музика]
Порошенко Дорогі
українці я щиро вітаю всіх вас з Днем
українського
прапору для мене як і для мільйонів
українців
це свято одне
із самих важливих в Україні тому що
український прапор
це не просто
символ незалежної сильної
України а для багатьох
сучасників він став
нагадуванням високої
ціни яку ми продовжуваємо
сплачувати за нашу свободу і
незалежність останні
роки прапор і
гімн набули для нас особливої
важливості саме гімн ми співаємо
тоді коли
відбуваються дуже серйозні національні
події і
відчуваємо велике
піднесення і
гордість коли бачимо сині-жовтий прапор
який
маярить серед без
прапорів інших
країн і саме під цими
кольорами Я зараз про тебе скажу саме
під всіми кольорами
ми ми захищаємо нашу кортиру
ми будуємо нашу країну
виховуємо молоде
покоління українських патріоті таких як
тиітай я в стрімі трохи пізніше стрім
закінчиться підходьте будь ласка нашим
рбом і нашим синя жоким прапором Слава
Україні Слава
живе Беларусь але зараз тепер можна
взяти ручки і маркери і лишити на цьому
прапорі своє побажання загадати те що
прийнято загадувати
під національними бборами саме на майда
друзі вже настав ваш час ви я маю надію
що писали в коментарях що нам написати
на прапорі ми з Андрієм будемо писати
придумайте що би ви написали і ми
обов'язково скористаємось вашими ідеями
і залишимо таке побажання від нас усіх
разом я напишу не тільки від себе а і
від вас тому що ви зараз не тут ви
дивитесь з нами дистанційно але я
обов'язково зроблю це за нас всіх так
буде така в мене місія Тому зараз буду
читати чат і знайдемо що нам написати і
обов'язково залишимо Тут також частинку
нашої всієї YouTube родини обов'язково
підписуйтесь на YouTube щоб бути в курсі
всіх стрімів щоби ви одразу ж отримували
сповіщення потрібно поставити дзвіночок
там є на нього треба натиснути щоб Ви
отримували сповіщення що у нас тут
прямий ефір наприклад і якщо дивиться в
Фейсбуці треба підписа а якщо дивитесь в
Фейсбуці зараз всім фейсбуку привіт то
обов'язково підписуйтесь на сторінку
Facebook і також там є функція поставити
всі
сповіщення я не пам'ятаю я думаю що ви
знайдете яка там кнопка там точно є коли
підписуєшся обрати режим всі сповіщення
і воно такою зірочкою помічається і во
вони ви отримуєте всі сповіщення про
нові записи одразу ж тому також
facebbook
дивляться зараз через Facebook чи через
YouTube напишіть так в коментарях ви
зараз дивитесь через Facebook чи через
YouTube і ми будемо знати звідки ви нас
дивитесь цей прапор ваші підписи на
марші єдності пройде поруч із людьми які
викорювали незалежність
[музика]
України
винахва щоб Україна
пона А чого Україна
серце бачу YouTube Харків
дивиться Ну що
таке Я чекаю ваших коментарів Що
написати на прапорі покажи мені
[музика]
час
я вже
написала Да ти вже мене
[музика]
маркела я все життя пишу на прапорах
одне і те ж саме я пишу що все буде
Україна я пишу так А що тобі
написати а зараз ми прочитаємо
Папа па
з Україною в серці треба писати з
Україною в серці напишу Напишу з
Україною в серці треба знайти дочекатись
вільне місце Ходімо шукати можливість
дістатись до прапора поближче
мі дру нам збою з
тобо
со
мі
А ви думаєте тут є вільне місце щоб
написати
щось єє місце о є
місце рідне
село
шльга так о там є місце я дотягнусьва
руку не треба заберіть
заберіть Давайте давайте нормально
нормально заберіть заберіть за паспорт я
тримаю Бачите як
добре Ану витримайте
собі
підпис друзі Як змогла від нас усіх Ми
переможемо осьмі
під
Вітаю Вітаю
вас Андрій твоя
черга якщо ви бачите що щось літає це
люди кидають один одному маркери щоб
могли
підписати
супер шикарно Я дуже рада що змогла і
мала змогу долучитись до цієї події тому
що як на мене це має велике значення для
дійсно об'єднання всіх
людей а спробуй якось
[музика]
можливо рапників хливи продажниши
рапників полистатили
доця в початку во зачену цтку за герої
руютьрарами нічого не просять а навіть
дуже погано аінони ці ненося крано
гіпотези ши пла за стає се сіно
імитьсяя гліно і постилісти
сяхле що нали пой на лісло і ди щоться і
за ти неібо пам'ятьстатами і діти
щасливі з мамами татами ротима мудрими і
багатимибити за
я
[музика]
шановні друзі обережно кілька кроків
назад не набирайте тому що
тутредині як вам такий
ракурс найкращий кадр найкращиі кадр зі
всіх стрімів з початку року я вам так
скажущощо
Так я не знаю оператору лайк дівчинки
лайк прапору
лайклак луганському обов'язково
вподобайку поставити поставити
вподобайку цьому відео щоби його
поширити якомога більше якщо ви дивитесь
нас у Facebook то обов'язково поширити в
Facebook щоби більше людей нас побачили
і більше людей долучились до такого
стріму А ще бачите прапо Білорусі люди
принесли підримки назад але перед тим і
без цього не може минути жодна акція на
Майдані
Незалежності зараз буде гімн Я так думаю
не
вмерла України
ні слава ні воля
Ще нам
браття
українці
усміхнеться
доля
здуть
наші
рожені як роса на
сонці запанує
ми браття у свої
сторонці Душу й тіло ми
положим за нашу
свободу і
покаже що ми браття
козацького
пророду Душу й тіло ми
положем за нашу
свободу І
покажем що ми
браття
козацького
роду Слава Україні Героям слава Слава
нації Смерть вога Україна зас і слава
українському державному
право Слава сла
Слава А тепер дяка всім хто прийшов на
цей
шмов